[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le conflit
ukrainien qui montre des signes
d'apaisement grâce à la coopération
internationale cependant la classe
politique du craignent elles restent
très divisés sur le sujet et le chemin
vers la paix sera très difficile pour le
nouveau président zielinski la crise du
crédit n verra-t-elle une porte de
sortie dans les relations russo
ukrainiennes des lignes commencent à
bouger fin 2019 les deux pays si un
nouveau contrat de transit gazier pour
cinq ans l'autre signe de détente l
échange récent de prisonniers entre kiev
et les rebelles de l'est de l'ukraine
le premier du genre depuis 2017 cet
échange est le fruit d'un compromis
atteint un sommet au format normandie en
décembre 2019 après des heures de
discussions les dirigeants français
allemand russe et ukrainien annonce
avoir rédigé une liste de mesures pour
la sortie de crise mais pourra-t-elle
être mises en oeuvre
car la pression sur zelensky se renforce
en interne les nationalistes ukrainiens
entre autres partis se pose à sa
politique
elle accuse de trahison des
manifestations d'envergure secoue le
pays depuis octobre 2010
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur ce conflit sanglant qui
continuent de déchirer l'est de
l'ukraine
c'est le blitz les premières violences
débute en 2014 majoritairement
russophone la population des régions de
donetsk de lougansk se révèle face à la
prise du pouvoir des partisans de
l'homme et dans quelle considèrent comme
un coup d'état
kiev riposte par une opération militaire
qui continue jusqu'à nos jours les
régions rebelles réclament la misty le
droit de disposer de ses propres forces
de l'ordre du statut officiel de la
langue russe et d'une autonomie élargie
la feuille de route de sortie de crise
et négocié durant les deux premières
années du conflit il s'agit des accords
de minsk il prévoit en premier lieu un
cessez le feu des deux côtés et un
désengagement sur toute la ligne de
front s'en suivrait des mesures
politiques à savoir la réforme
constitutionnelle l'adoption de la loi
sur le statut spécial du donbass ont
encore la tenue des élections locales
dans les régions rebelles en 2015
enfin de préciser le mécanisme
d'exécution des deux derniers points
frank walter steinmeier ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères de
l'époque propose l'algorithme suivant
les régions rebelles pourraient obtenir
temporairement un statut spécial le jour
des élections locales
ce ne serait qu après la reconnaissance
de ces élections par le est ce que ce
statut spécial deviendrait permanent
connu sous le nom de formule stand mayer
cette initiative devrait être intégré
dans la législation ukrainienne selon
l'accord attend au sommet au format
normandie en descend les premiers signes
de dégel apparaissent enfin dans le
conflit ukrainien fin décembre 2019 kiev
et les régions rebelles de donetsk et de
lougansk procèdent à l'échangé de
prisonniers l'opération est le fruit
d'un accord à temps au sommet au format
normandie en décembre 2019 première
réunion quadripartite au plus haut
niveau depuis trois ans elle débouche
sur un accord
un cessez le feu complet l'intégration
de la formule steinmeier dans la
législation ukrainienne et enfin le
désengagement dans trois nouveaux points
du front les quatre pays participants
l'ont confirmé encore une fois il n'y a
pas d'alternative aux accords de minsk
qui reste la base du processus de paix
cependant les désaccords persistent par
exemple le président ukrainien se bat
bec et ongles pour rétablir le contrôle
sur la frontière avec la russie avant la
tenue des élections locales prévues par
les accords de minsk la russie invoque
ces mêmes accords et ainsi sur l'ordre
inverse d'abord les élections le
contrôle ensuite moscou prône aussi le
désengagement sur toute la ligne du
front
volodymyr zélés ce qu'ils refusent
pourtant d'en parler pour l'instant
comment explique-t-il sa position
quelles actions se sont suivis côté
ukrainien après la réunion de paris
à quels obstacles la réalisation des
accords de mixeur peut-elle pour
répondre à ces questions nous rejoignons
pierre laurin écrivain auteur de
l'ukraine une histoire entre deux
destins ouvrage paru aux éditions
bartillat monsieur laurin bonjour
bonjour
grâce à quoi pensez-vous la reprise des
rencontres au format normandie au plus
haut niveau est elle devenue finalement
possible bien il y à un élément
déterminant qui a été l'élection du
président volodymyr zelensky en ukraine
qui a complètement débloqué la situation
puisqu'il a été élu avec 73% des
suffrages au second tour sur un
programme qui prévoyait expressément la
recherche de la paix dans le donbass
donc il a un mandat indiscutable du
peuple ukrainien pour réaliser une
approche vers la paix et cette approche
vers la paix ne pouvait se faire
évidemment que par la négociation
et d'abord dans la reprise des accords
de minsk et par la médiation des
puissances que sont celles du format
normandie c'est à dire la france
l'allemagne et bien entendu la russie
justement comment évaluez-vous le rôle
de la france notamment d' emmanuel
macron et de l'allemagne dans ce
processus vers la résolution du conflit
dans le donbass
je crois que le rapprochement entre eux
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine date
maintenant de plusieurs mois et même de
pratiquement le début du mandat de
d'emmanuel maquereau en france c'est à
dire le mois de mai 2017
ce rapprochement se fait par petites
touches parce que comme vous le savez
l'image de l'afld de l'ue de la russie
en france et les images de vladimir
poutine en france n'est pas très bonne
est donc le président macro ne pouvait
pas changer complètement le paradigme
actuel qui régit l'opinion en france et
donc il a procédé par petites touches et
cette entente qui s'est concrétisée
d'une manière absolument radicales au
moment de l'été dernier au moment de la
rencontre entre les deux présidents au
fort de brégançon cette entente a permis
de réunir le format normandie dans les
meilleurs délais
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
est restée un peu en retrait mais elle
n'a pas contrairement à ce qui se
passait précédemment avec le président
françois hollande qui était profondément
anti russe et qui ne facilitait pas du
tout les discussions au format normandie
là en gala merkel était beaucoup plus
conciliante et donc hélas permis même
avec des réticences qui se sont
manifestés tout de suite après le sommet
de faire avancer la situation de toute
façon il ne pouvait pas en être
autrement à partir du moment où les deux
principaux concernés qui sont le
président de lienz qui est le président
poutine était favorable aller de l'avant
avec des conditions etc
mais aller de l'avant et ça a été
concrétisé tout de suite après le sommet
dans les quelques semaines qui ont suivi
dans les trois semaines qui ont suivi
par un échange total des prisonniers de
parts et d'août
merci beaucoup monsieur laurent nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons en fin
d'émission
pour plus de détails sur la question
merci les premiers progrès apparaissent
dans les relations russo ukrainiennes le
30 décembre 2019 kiev et moscou
s'accordent sur un nouveau contrat de
zut gazier finalisé la veille de
l'expiration du contrat précédent le
nouvel accord a permis d'éviter la
situation de 2006 et de 2009 lorsque la
livraison de gaz russe pour l'europe
avait été interrompue selon ce document
le géant gazier russe gazprom fera
transiter via le territoire ukrainien au
moins 65 milliards de mètres cubes de
gaz l'année prochaine puis au moins 40
milliards par an de 2021 à 2024 côté
ukrainien les bénéfices seraient estimés
à plus de 7 milliards de dollars
en outre gazprom et naftogaz déclare
avoir terminé une âpre bataille
judiciaire conformément à une décision
de l'arbitrage de stock gold le géant
russe a accepté de payer 2,9 milliards
de dollars à naftogaz
en échange la compagnie gazière
ukrainienne abandonnent toutes les
autres poursuites judiciaires visant
gazprom pour un montant total dépassant
les 12 milliards de dollar en pas majeur
est également franchi sur le chemin de
la désescalade dont le conflit armé qui
meurtrit le dombass le 29 décembre kiev
et les rebelles de l'est de l'ukraine
procède à un échange des prisonniers
l'opération d'échangé de prisonniers la
première depuis 2000 17 se déroule au
point de contrôle de majorque dans la
partie de la région de john yates
contrôlée par kg est très attendu des
deux côtés ce pas symbolique a permis la
libération de deux cents personnes
cent vingt-quatre d'entre elles sont
remises par kiev aux républiques
autoproclamées de deux nièces et de
l'ogc ans celle-ci de leur côté ont
libéré soixante seize prisonniers
cette opération est devenu possible
grâce à la reprise du format normandie
au plus haut niveau
début décembre 2019 les dirigeants
ukrainiens russes allemands et français
se réunissent à paris un sommet
particulièrement attendu car il s'agit
notamment de la première rencontre entre
et les skis et vladimir poutine en tout
les négociations durent près de huit
heures selon les participants
le débat est plus qu'animé à la fin du
sommet les dirigeants des quatre pays
donne cependant une conférence de presse
où il annonce avoir réussi à rédiger une
liste de mesures pour faire avancer la
résolution du conflit en plus de
l'échangé de prisonniers le document
prévoit l'instauration d'un cessez le
feu complet d'ici fin 2010 9 le contrôle
et la surveillance du processus sont
confiés à l'eau c'est eux qui devra
disposer d'un
accès sécurisé à tout le territoire
ukrainien 24 heures sur 24
l'autre mesure décidée à paris porte sur
le désengagement militaire dans trois
zones disputées d'ici fin mars 2020
avant juste la tenue du sommet le
retrait des troupes a déjà été effectué
sur trois points de la ligne de front
steinitz à longages callas de l'hôtelier
et petrov ce collier côté juridique une
avancée majeure voit le jour aussi kiev
se déclare prêt à intégrer la formule
steinmeier dans la loi fixant le statut
spécial du dombass cette formule prévoit
que le statut spécial permanent sera
accordée aux territoires rebelles après
la tenue des élections locales
celles ci devront se dérouler dans le
cadre de la loi ukrainienne être
reconnus par le est ce enfin les quatre
chefs d'état ont réitéré leur
attachement aux accords de mise qu'il
considère comme la base du règlement
dans le conflit dans le donbass ce
dialogue au plus haut niveau va se
poursuivre avec une nouvelle rencontre
au format normandie prévue pour avril
2020 des résultats que l'ukraine et la
russie considère comme un pas important
vers la paix cette opinion est également
partagée par les co médiateur de la
rencontre que sont l'allemagne et la
france
je veux ici redire combien les
discussions du jour y compris les
discussions inédite
si je puis dire ont permis d'avancer
utilement pour la première fois depuis
un peu plus de trois ans je devais
remettre à dire qu'en dépit de tous les
problèmes que nous constatons je suis
satisfaite de l'art d'aujourd'hui
à peine le sommet terminé les premières
actions se dessine le 12 décembre le
parlement ukrainien prolonge d'un an
la loi sur le statut spécial du donbass
c'est ici à arriver à l'échéance fin
2019 une décision accueillie
positivement par moscou quant au futur
sommet par exemple en avril il sera
pertinent s'il ya des changements
positifs
existe-t-il ou non il y en a
premièrement la loi sur le statut
spécial a été prolongée ensuite le 13
décembre 2019 le gie meilleurs élèves
qui introduit au parlement le projet
d'une réforme constitutionnelle ayant
pour objectif la décentralisation du
pouvoir
une des mesures clés prévus par les
accords de minsk
le document devra apporter des
changements profonds dans le système
administrative et territoriale du pays
la subdivision territoriale sera
simplifiée alors que l'administration
territoriale sera réformé en outre la
liste des régions ukrainienne sera
retirée de la constitution les
procédures d'instauration de suppression
de changements de frontières de
dénomination et de ré nomination des
régions seront désormais est régulée par
une loi
à part pour être adoptée la réforme doit
obtenir les deux tiers des voix au
parlement
et pendant que céline ce qu'ils
cherchent à convaincre les législateurs
moscou se dit préoccupé par les projets
annoncés selon les autorités russes
les changements voulus par zelensky ne
prennent pas en compte certains points
des accords de musique
contrairement aux accords de minsk il
n'y a pas un mot sur le statut spécial
du donbass qui devrait être inscrit dans
la constitution
toutes ces questions doivent également
être clarifiés mais dans les accords de
minsk il est écrit que si il s'agit du
dombass cela doit être coordonnée avec
ces régions il n'y a pas de coordination
c'est évidemment alarmant alors pourquoi
la mise en oeuvre des accords de mise
peine-t-elle toujours à se réaliser
quels sont les problèmes restés non
résolus au sommet quels sont les défis
qui se dessinent interne devant zelensky
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la crise ne craignait ne connaît donc un
certain dégel ce résultat est largement
due à la coopération entre les
dirigeants russes ukrainiens allemand et
français
c'est dans ce format que les quatre pays
cherchent une solution depuis 2000 14
avril 2014 marque le début du conflit
dans le don de base qui oppose l'armée
ukrainienne et les rebelles des régions
de donetsk et de lougansk
majoritairement russophone
ces derniers se révoltent contre la
prise de pouvoir en ukraine par les
partisans de rom hayden en 2014 et leur
menace d'annuler le statut régional de
la langue russe qui avait les pays
occidentaux accusent la russie de
soutenir les rebelles militairement et
financièrement ce que la russie nie en
bloc pour tenter de calmer les tensions
françois hollande organise le 6 juin
en marge des commémorations du
débarquement en normandie une réunion
entre la france et l'allemagne ainsi que
la russie et l'ukraine au plus haut
niveau
ce rendez-vous à 4 a depuis pris le nom
de formats normandie s'ensuit alors une
série de réunions et d'entretiens
téléphoniques afin de trouver une
solution
pourtant pendant ce temps là les combats
dans l'est de l'ukraine se poursuivre
après de longues négociations le
protocole de minsk où minsk 1-1 signé
entre les représentants de la russie et
de l'ukraine ainsi que des républiques
autoproclamées de dounia sq est lougansk
et de l'oas et le 5 septembre 2014
ce protocole prévoit un cessez le feu
immédiat entre les forces armées
ukrainiennes et les rebelles de donetsk
est lougansk il dresse aussi les grandes
lignes du règlement du conflit telles
que la libération des otages et la mise
en place d'une zone de sécurité à la
frontière russo ukrainienne
l'ukraine de son côté doit mener une
réforme constitutionnelle fixant le
statut spécial de dos nièce et de
lougansk ces dernières doivent organiser
des élections locales conformément à la
loi ukrainienne
l'intensité des combats dans l'est du
pays a certes été réduite mais il
continue en février 2015 les dirigeants
du quatuor du format normandie se
réunissent à nouveau afin de relancer
les efforts de paix après de longues
négociations il signe un nouvel accord
minsk 2 qui établit un nouveau cessez le
feu ainsi qu'une feuille de route afin
de sortir de l'impasse et faire
respecter le protocole de minsk initial
pourtant le processus de paix continue
de patiner le cessez-le-feu a été violé
à de multiples reprises par les deux
parties et il n'y a pas eu de retrait
complet des armes lourdes et le
principal point de blocage et l'absence
de la réforme constitutionnelle et
d'élections dans les régions de deux
nièces et de lougansk afin de débloquer
la situation le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères de l'époque franz
walter steinmeier propose en 2015 un
mécanisme pour mettre en oeuvre la
réforme constitutionnelle et organiser
les élections en octobre 2016 les
grandes lignes de cette formule
steinmeier ont été accordés lors d'un
sommet au format normandie mais les
progrès se heurte aux désaccords
concernant les détails c'est la dernière
rencontre format normandie au plus haut
niveau
certes les conversations téléphoniques
et les rencontres des ministres des
affaires étrangères se poursuivent mais
elles commencent aussi à s'essouffler
ainsi en 2010 est en 2018 il n'y a eu
que deux rencontres entre les chefs de
diplomatie en 2019
il n'y a eu aucune jusqu'à celle de
décembre à paris alors que les tensions
se poursuivent volodymyr hélène ce qui
est élu président de l'ukraine en avril
le nouveau président promet de faire de
la résolution du conflit son cheval de
bataille et se dit prêt à rouvrir le
dialogue avec mouscron et les premiers
progrès commencent à voir le jour en
septembre 2019 kiev moscou procès d'un
échange de prisonniers le 1er octobre
2019 zelensky si la formule steinmeier
enfin le 9 décembre 2019
une réunion au format normandie a eu
lieu après trois ans de gel des
négociations
ceux qui lancent un regain d'espoir
pourtant plusieurs obstacles restent
encore à franchir sur la route vers la
paix tout d'abord la première clause
crucial des accords de minsk 2 n'ait
toujours pas rempli le cessez le feu
n'est pas respecté malgré plusieurs
tentatives de l'instaurer depuis 2015
lors de la dernière rencontre à paris le
format normandie s'accordent sur une
cessation des hostilités avant 2020
cependant les belligérants s'accuse
toujours mutuellement cas de provocation
difficile donc de passer à l'étape
suivante le retrait des forces de la
ligne de front
c'était pourtant l'un des principaux
objectifs que s'était fixés
volodymyr zielinski l'étape suivante est
la solution définitive au problème du
retrait des troupes
the l'hôtelier et petro ce cru est
d'abord et ensuite un retrait sur toute
la longueur de la ligne de contact dans
des délais précis une intention
honorable qui se heurte à la réalité de
l'opinion publique car même la première
étape s'est avérée complexe à mettre en
oeuvre et l'inscrit commence le retrait
en été 2019 depuis trois localités
les militaires auraient dû les quitter
dès 2016 selon les décisions prises à
minsk mais les nationalistes ukrainiens
s'y opposer farouchement à de l'hôtelier
des centaines de combattants de
bataillons de volontaires d'extrême
droite prennent position en défiant
l'ordre du président par mieux le fameux
bataillon azoff qui a longtemps
participé dans la guerre du côté de kate
volodymyr zelensky doit finalement allé
sur place pour convaincre
personnellement les nationalistes de
commencer le retrait sans surprise le
leader ukrainien atténué depuis sa
position à paris en décembre
il ne parle plus du retrait sur toute la
ligne de front désormais le format
normandie s'accordent autour d'un
retrait des troupes de trois nouvelles
de qualité fin mars 2020 ce détail
montre bien l'énorme pression exercée
sur le président ukrainien par une
partie de l'opposition
début octobre quand la formule
steinmeier est signé par kiev une vague
de protestations secoue le pays de la
capitale jusqu aux petites villes
partout des membres de bataillon
nationalistes et des membres des partis
de l'opposition descendent dans la rue
pour dénoncer une trahison même lors du
sommet à paris des activistes campé près
du bureau du président à kiev
cette vague de contestation de minorité
très active n'a pas de leaders
politiques définies une opportunité pour
l'ancien président ukrainien petro
porochenko alors que c'est lui qui a
signé des accords de minsk aujourd'hui
il critique les étapes menant à leur
réalisation
et quand la communauté internationale
salue les résultats de la rencontre à
paris petro porochenko lui montre une
autre opinion qu'il n'y a pas de raison
d'être euphorique
la rencontre a montré qu'on ne peut pas
faire confiance à la russie qu'il n'y a
pas de court chemin vers la paix
adoption de la formule steinmeier
échange de prisonniers encore
proposition de modifier la constitution
toutes ces avancées de vladimir zelensky
sont farouchement attaqué par ses
opposants politiques
ainsi malgré une majorité confortable
parlement et le soutien populaire le
président doit naviguer prudemment vers
la réconciliation
ainsi il adopte une position inflexible
sur la question de la frontière
aujourd'hui dans l'est la frontière
était contrôlée par les rebelles
les accords domise stipule une fois les
élections locales dans les régions
rebelles organisé et reconnue à
l'international la frontière pas sous le
contrôle de kate moss pour insiste aussi
sur cet ordre déjà validé pourtant
l'ukraine veut en changer kiev voudrait
d'abord retrouver le contrôle sur la
frontière a ensuite que se tiennent les
élections
l'ukraine souhaite organiser ces
élections locales en 2020 au même moment
que dans le reste du pays
néanmoins la frontière est une question
de principe sur lequel aucune des
parties ne veut céder si moscou invoque
les accords de mise qui reste en vigueur
kiev répond en proposant une solution
radicale pourquoi ne pas les modifier
nous comprenons que ce n'est pas mon
équipe qui a signé minsk mais nous
devons nous conformer aux conditions
acceptées par le pouvoir à cette époque
je suis certain que nous pouvons
modifier et modifieront certains points
car un transfert de la frontière de
l'état ukrainien sous notre contrôle qui
aurait lieu après les élections ne
correspond absolument pas notre position
cette insistance de kiev se heurtent à
l'intransigeance de mousse ou le kremlin
refuse catégoriquement de réviser les
accords de mix of à une condition
l'établissement d'un dialogue direct
entre kiev et les dirigeants des régions
rebelles se quitte à son tour
inacceptables pour l'ukraine dans cette
impasse un compromis est il possible à
court d'options moscou et kiev se voit
proposer une version par une partie
étrangère au format normandie les états
unis qu'il peut y avoir un compromis
il y à une phase de transition durant
laquelle les russes pourraient donner le
contrôle à une force élargie de
l'orestie eu une mission des nations
unies où une force internationale pour
surveiller la frontière et assurer la
sécurité dans le donbass de façon à
pouvoir organiser des élections une
solution similaire avait déjà été
proposée par vladimir poutine en 2017 et
casques bleus de l'onu sur la ligne de
front pour protéger la mission de
lesseux et les rejetés par les états
unis au conseil de sécurité de
lui pourtant si washington use de son
droit de veto les etats-unis ne
participent pas au format normandie pour
pouvoir proposer eux-mêmes des
initiatives et c'est ce que l'ukraine
propose de changer selon son ministre
des affaires étrangères quatre pays
veulent rejoindre le format normandie
les etats unis le royaume uni le canada
et la pologne et la commission
européenne seraient également intéressés
néanmoins du côté des membres existants
du format l'idée ne rencontre pas l'
enthousiasme moscou et berlin se disent
carrément contre et pour paris l'idée
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
peut-on vraiment pensé modifier le
format normandie alors que les accords
de misc commence à peine et leur
application
verra-t-on des résultats concrets de
leur rencontre à paris dans les mois qui
viennent pour mieux comprendre les
perspectives de réconciliation
nous rejoignons à nouveau pierre laurin
écrivain auteur de l'ukraine une
histoire entre deux destins ouvrage paru
aux éditions bartillat monsieur laurin
presque chaque pas fait parler les skis
vers la résolution du conflit dans l'eau
dont basse et la normalisation des
relations avec moscou soeur de critique
farouche de l'opposition et des
nationalistes ukrainiens pensez vous
qu'à un certain moment leurs opinions
puissent constituer un obstacle
infranchissable sur le chemin de la paix
un obstacle oui indiscutablement il sait
ces gens les partis d'opposition
particulier les partis nationalistes qui
pour la plupart sont des partis
d'extrême droite et qui sont soutenues
par des forces politiques à l'intérieur
du pays
par exemple l'ancien président prochaine
coquille qui était à 100% avec eux
pendant toute la période de sa
présidence mais également par des forces
hors les frontières du crânienne en
particulier par certains milieux
néoconservateurs américains qui voient
la situation en ukraine yens leur
échapper pour les néoconservateurs
américains l'ukraine était une pièce
essentielle dans le dispositif de
containment de la russie or là soudain
s'il n'y a plus de conflits dans le
donbass ils perdent un moyen de pression
non seulement sur l'ukraine mais
également sur l'ensemble de l'europe
puisque c'est t
en fonction des tensions de l'ukraine
que l'otan a pris de l'importance ces
derniers - surtout qu'elle a trouvé une
un justificatif à son existence donc
pour les néo conservateurs c'est très
délicat et pour l'opposition ukrainienne
les néo naissent les nationalistes
presque néo nazis pour certains
d'ailleurs il est paradoxal que le kiev
soit la seule capitale européenne où on
ferme les yeux sur des défis les néo
nazis
partout où ils sont interdits en europe
sauf en ukraine
bon ça c'est un point 2-2 à une
parenthèse maintenant eu l' avantage de
zelensky c'est que il a été élu par 73%
de la population c'est à dire il n'a pas
caché qu'il voulait la paix il n'a pas
caché qu'il était pour l'harmonie entre
les différentes parties du pays que il
faisait ses discours à moitié en
ukrainien à moitié en russe c'est à dire
qu'il montrait le jeu il montrait ce que
devait être l'ukraine qu'il voulait
c'est à dire un endroit où personne ne
se sentirait exclu surtout les
russophones qui était réellement sous
une pression politique considérable
depuis les cinq dernières années
je voudrais simplement revenir sur
l'opposition interne
est-ce que selon vous c'est la raison
pour laquelle il pourrait avoir de
nouveaux désaccords parce que
l'opposition appelle à réviser certains
points des accords de minsk quoi qu'il
en soit est ce possible compte tenu de
la position de moscou qui se prononce
contre les modifications de ces accords
enfin ma question est comment zelensky
va jongler entre les deux jallet qui n'a
pas besoin de jongler réellement parce
que les accords de minsk sont
intangibles
on ne peut pas les remettre en cause la
partie ukrainienne a accepté les accords
de minsk en février 2015
et cela sous la médiation et sous le
regard vigilant de la france et de
l'allemagne
c'est à dire que la france et
l'allemagne ne sont pas favorables à la
renégociation des accords de minsk et
encore moins bien entendu la russie donc
les accords de minsk doivent s'appliquer
c'est la loi internationale qui le veut
or nous savons tous que la loi
internationale se place au dessus de la
loi intérieure des pays donc il est très
difficile pour l'opposition de vouloir
imposer quelque chose alors que tout est
écrit
la seule chose qui peut se produire qui
pourrait se produire c'est
qu'effectivement l'ukraine se retire
unilatérale unilatéralement de
l'application des accords comme elle l'a
fait au cours des cinq dernières années
mais ça aujourd'hui avec dia lenski
comme président ce n'est pas
envisageable parce que s'il fait ça il
devient un prochain kobe ce et il sera
évidemment à l'encontre il ira à
l'encontre de ses engagements pendant
toute sa campagne électorale et de tout
ce que l'on a vu depuis qu'il est
président merci beaucoup
pierre le rhin pour cet éclairage je
rappelle vous êtes écrivain auteur de
l'ukraine une histoire entre deux
destins ouvrage paru aux éditions
bartillat cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rtl
[Musique]